>>Male Presenter: This is Roy Freed; he will
be our speaker today.
Roy and I know each other first from the Bulgarian
community.
My mother in law and he knew each other from
a while back.
And he was the first to publish a paper on
computer law in 1960 and he will be talking
about from working on computer law from 1960
to the modern law of the mind.
>>Roy Freed: Thank you.
My wife and I were very fortunate in that.
Thank you so very much for coming, I sure
appreciate this and I hope that I can stimulate
you to be curious and engage with me, maybe
at lunch with some discussion.
I'm eager to get critiques and comments so
I can learn.
As I started to say, my wife at age 72, we're
fortunate to have Fulbright Fellowships in
Bulgaria of all places and by a very interesting
series of coincidences, I'm writing my autobiography
now and all these items are pouring out of
me and I hope that eventually, if it gets
published, it will attract people.
But in any event, here I am.
And I've been lured into talking about my
great fortune of discovering computer law.
In 1960, in the middle of my career, previous
to that time I was a late bloomer and I sadly
got involved with litigation in large anti-trust
cases with massive files.
It was onerous both psychological and physically
managing these papers without the computer
help that would eventually, were created.
But I must say I'm glad that they didn't develop
those systems while I was active, it might
have lured me to stay in that field, which
I didn't like, so I'm glad they delayed that
a bit.
I happen to have, by good fortune, an innate
engineering aptitude; I didn't realize that
until late in life.
But I happened to take advantage of that as
things went along in various fields in which
I worked.
When I was down in Philadelphia, really desperate
working on anti-trust cases, suddenly in 1959
actually, computers were first commercialized
and my engineering aptitude enabled me immediately
to grasp what the technology was all about.
It seem to bewilder other people but I was
very fortunate in that immediately I could
recognize not only what they were about but
also I started to think in my usual sort of
preventive way about the possible legal implications
of having computers used and available.
And so I was inspired promptly to write an
article called "The Lawyers Guide through
the Computer Maze" and I was very fortunate
to find Paul Wolkin, the editor of The Practical
Lawyer, a publication of the Joint Committee
on Continuing Professional Education of the
American Bar Association and the American
Law Institute in Philadelphia.
And he immediately embraced the article and
published it.
I was fortunate I found him because they were
no editors, law students primarily of the
traditional law journals who ever would have
touched it because it was so different from
the traditional footnoted articles, ponderous
articles.
And that was a great fortune, good fortune
for me.
Paul not only published it but gave me free
200 copies of reprints that I could distribute.
Of course I immediately got the idea that
I'd like to develop a private practice and
also he, on his own initiative, that I would
be general chairman of seven continuing education
programs throughout the country.
So it was a great boost to me.
I was able, as a real lawyer, rather than
a lawyer that came from a engineering background,
to realize the intellectual and legal implications
of computers being available.
And I readily discovered that they were very
similar to existing law issues because computers
were simply used either in place of or to
supplement human minds.
So I was, I enjoyed that aspect and I wrote
countless articles and wonderful thing was
that computer law turned out to be the magic
carpet for my wife and myself.
It enabled us to travel throughout the world
for me to be the guru and give lectures and
it was absolutely wonderful.
I enjoyed that from 1960 until 1986 when I
retired.
And figure if I retired in 1986 I'm quite
much older than all of you combined [chuckles].
What I found fascinating was that while I
was satisfied with computer law and what I
really, really came to enjoy was my retirement.
Computer law was my avenue to deeper thinking
in retirement and if you have questions about
computer law and if it triggers your mind,
I'd be delighted to answer your questions.
First, I should say I found implications in
practically all fields of law.
I wrote articles about the tax implications
about the intellectual property implications
and tort implications as involving civil wrongs.
I found them in all fields and a natural development
from those fields.
And intellectual property, I would say that
obviously evoked copyright and it was amazing
how, I'm bragging now, how I readily appreciated
the technology but other people simply couldn't
grasp it.
And when computer people devised the term
'program' that really threw people.
There was an effort to patent a program, the
first effort.
And it got to the Supreme Court and Justice
Douglas, who was a very bright and wonderful
man, who spoke his opinion and said that computer
programs, they're not patentable but that
doesn't necessarily mean they never would
be.
He had no idea what he was talking about and
neither did the lawyers handling the case.
They simply couldn't understand that a program
is a process and processes are patentable
if they are practical and deal with the, especially
with tangible things.
People couldn't understand tangibility, the
physical nature of electromagnetic pulse signals
in computers.
It was way beyond their imagination and it
remains so today, astonishingly.
Well, I wrote an article pointing out the
analogy between the technology of computers
and other types of technology.
And I haven't had fun that way, I'd like to
stand out, I have a strong ego and it enabled
me to become a real person after struggling
with that awful anti-trust litigation.
Well, what I, my message really is how a mind
evolves.
And my mind evolved from computers.
It's fascinating and I'm so thrilled, computers
have made me, as a person, first, by getting
into computer law and I had to struggle there,
I became active with a committee of the American
Bar Association called the Electronic Data
Retrieval Committee.
And they were focused only on searching the
vast law library and at that time, the technology
available was primitive with the electromagnetic
punch card system of IBM and Remington Rand
and then a young imaginative law professor
at the University of Pittsburgh was able to
wheedle 400,000 dollars from the Ford Foundation
to create a very modest computer batch processing
system to search the law cases.
And that was really the beginning but it was
so primitive and frustrating at the time.
And I was a pioneer in my group trying to
talk about legal issues and it didn't resonate
with them and, at one point, I had talked
about legal issues and taxation and how to
tax the, how to treat, for taxation purposes,
the expenses for creating programs and how
to deal with the income from their marketing.
And I did that and I suggested moving on to
other topics and one of the members of the
committee said "Well, you already covered
the legal issues" and it was so naive.
But in any event, I struggled through that
and I had a really great time.
There was an American Bar Association conference
in New York, probably in the early '80s and
I wrote a mock trial for that and we demonstrated
that, in New York, how to introduce computer
records into evidence.
Amazing but in the beginning there was so,
such ignorance about the nature of the records
and suspicion that they couldn't be reliable
but in many cases lawyers failed to file cases,
very valid cases, to recover money due because
of the concern lest they not persuade the
judge to accept them.
It was bizarre.
It's amazing how naive so many minds, bright
minds, can be.
And in that case it was interesting.
The chair of the business law committee agreed
to sponsor that presentation, that mock trial
and I got a very interesting judge, a district
court judge in New York to read it, preside
at it.
And the last minute, that chair withdrew his
sponsorship and the judge said, "we're going
on" and we did it and it was beautiful.
We read the text because we didn't have time
to prepare but it worked fine.
And eventually I sold it to a law book publisher
and got enough money to take my family on
a trip to Europe.
[chuckles]
But in any event, I did that very satisfactorily,
in fact my last legal work was for MIT.
I had, in a computer role, become especially
known for drafting contracts to describe the
technology in relationships.
Like, for example, for MIT they wanted Wachovia
Computer Services to take over the management
of the student loan program.
And Wachovia presented us with a standard
form contract, so called.
And it was really bizarre, even though they
were supposed to be knowledgeable and that
was their industry.
I redrafted it and presented mine and they
both readily accepted it.
And the bursar at MIT would repeatedly call
me and say how nice it was to have that agreement
in her drawer.
Because it was really a system design for
how to maintain that relationship and it worked
well.
So I left in a blaze of glory.
And there I was, retired and relieved of the
responsibility to make a living and that made
my mind available.
And it's wonderful how having time to think
and trying to think is so rewarding.
I mean, it really revealed to me, the fact
that I had a very good mind.
And it is thrilling to know your mind that
way.
And, but what it did was it enabled me to
stop thinking about the human by drawing a
broad analogy from computers.
Not long before that neuroscientists had finally
discovered that the human mind had, consists
of circuitry and that there are electrochemical
pulse signals that represent facts and ideas
that flow through that circuitry.
That immediately enabled me to start drawing
a very broad analogy with computers.
I mean, the parallels are so compelling and
I'm thinking deeply about that.
I realize that the ideal way to learn how
the opaque mind operates is by drawing analogies
and features into transparent computers.
It's amazing how that inferential technique,
along with introspection, is the ideal means
for non-scientists to discover what their
minds are really like.
It provides an ideal basis for comparison
and really the trick in that comparison to
realize that the human mind is superior to
computers by virtue of its creativity and
free will.
And that opens up such a universe of understanding,
self-understanding of understanding how society
works by interaction of minds.
And it opens up this very broad concept that
the whole world is actually a so-called information
processing system.
It's haphazard but it exists, it is.
But, I'm especially thrilled about is the
fact that by knowing how the mind operates
as such an animate autonomous machine, you
learn some of the nature and source of some
of the social problems that we have in society.
For example, the human mind arrives as a partial
blank slate, some people say as a blank slate
but that's not true.
It arrives with this wonderful potential array
of abilities.
A person eventually to become an adult, a
well-functioning adult.
But it lacks the knowledge for using those
great skills, but evolution, and it's all
so related to evolution.
Evolution arranged naturally that when each
human mind arrives with its partial blank
slate it automatically, from birth, starts
to receive input signals from the environment.
But who is the environment?
Immediately the parents and so by starting
with the parents it immediately starts to
embrace automatically their cultural values,
their patterns of life, and their religion,
their politics and that continues throughout
life as the environment expands from the parents.
And the-.
What I find well that makes each mind susceptible
to ideologies automatically and naturally.
I mean it's inevitable.
And I realized that the instinct to survive
which exists in order to protect the physical
structure of our body at the same time exists
to protect our point of view or our ego or
persona equally and against contradictions.
And the, it does so by argumentation, verbal
argumentation and also violence and that creates
social problems in society.
But I think that this functional perception
of the human mind that I'm describing as a
machine is so parallel to computers, enables
people to understand how the social problems
and personal problems arise and makes it,
if they're deep thinkers, should enable them
to realize that in order to protect and overcome
many of those problems, they should take advantage
of their creativity and free will and gain
an open mind that engages in critical thinking.
I have the theory that that's an ideal basis
for teaching, especially young people, how
to start thinking, how to start using their
minds constructively for their own benefit
and for the benefit of society if they would
think broadly enough.
This is the general context in which I've
been thinking deeply and I find it so amazingly
exciting I find having the opportunity to
think deeply on your own is just the most
precious experience that is imaginable.
It's an absolute delight, I can't tell you
how much I find it exciting and creative and
supporting my ego [laughs].
It makes me an important person in my own
estimation.
But what I find fascinating is that knowing
this general nature of the human mind I've
described, it becomes possible to find aspects
of it that are so interesting.
To get away from the generality to the specific.
For example, I came to realize, on my own,
and I do all of this independently.
I don't do research, I find, I can't find
parallel approaches to my thinking and also,
I'm selfish enough that I want to do it myself.
[chuckles] I want it to be my, my creation.
But in any event by thinking independent suddenly
I find the amazing subconscious, is so creative,
it, Freud's discovery of the unconscious,
discovered, or created a I think deceptive
term; because we're not unconscious we have
to be conscious.
But we have two levels of consciousness, the
subconscious and the awareness level.
And I'm so aware of my subconscious and how
it produces ideas on its own and sometimes
with the help of Google.
I can't tell you how invaluable Google is
as I do a lot of writing and I come across
a phrase or a word or things like that and
I have a feeling of the significance and I
say real easily I rely upon Google to help
me understand the accuracy and I constantly
do that.
I'm writing a very extensive autobiography
right now and I spend so much time diverting
from the composing to check and validate things
like that.
So I got the idea at one point, I don't know
where, it popped in my subconscious, and it's
so invaluable to nurture it and to benefit
from it.
The idea about experiencing art and knowing
how the mind operates on coded discreet batches
of electrochemical pulse signals that evolution
exploited.
That we experience everything that way, in
that functional way.
And, a, I have been involved with art, I've
made sculpture for 20 years from found objects
using the engineering part of my mind.
I was moved to write an article to describe
my perceptions of the functional aspects of
art.
And what I found was so interesting, I network
well, believe me it's wonderful.
And you live here [chuckles] and I work here,
I know this now.
But in Canton, Mass, where I live they have
a wonderful Canton Community TV System and
it's run by a very bright woman and in my
networking activity, I live in a retirement
community down in Canton.
I took initiative to get in touch with her
and she readily realized I apparently have
a contribution to make in my ideas and discussion.
And she, when I gave her my idea on art she
brought up the fact that Leo Tolstoy, a famous
Russian author had written an article entitled
"What is Art?"
I had no idea about that, I mean, the networking
is so invaluable for bringing out these resources
and it became so interesting how his notice
that art is simply the exercise of feeling.
And I would define art as all activities that
produce human feeling which is so fundamental
to human existence.
And I found it fascinating to find his, Tolstoy's,
abstract concept so parallel to my functional
concept and I wrote an article about the functional
aspect of art with his, with Tolstoy's ideas
in the background.
And it turned out to be an actually beautiful
article and recently she and I had a conversation
on her TV and produced a half an hour program
and it's just exciting.
And it's so, I think perfect for non-scientists,
that's the important aspect of what I'm doing
and thinking about.
Because I am a non-scientist, I can assimilate
and grasp a neuroscientist concept and I think
that through the functional understanding
of the human mind, it becomes more possible
to grasp what neuroscientists are discovering
and describing.
And so I find that it's an ideal vehicle to
reach and educate non-scientists from this
basic approach.
And I've talked for about a half hour now
and I would love it if I have stimulated,
triggered things in your mind, if you would
respond, if you would validate what I say.
I love validation, but also if you'd criticize,
because I'm concerned that in my self-focus
that I might be off the wall in some respects,
which I would not want to do.
So I invite you people to help me, and I came
here for the help.
Thank you.
OK
>>Male #1: Computer scientists, great challenges
trying to emulate certain ways that the human
mind thinks.
>>Roy Freed: yeah.
>>Male #1: I mean there are obviously big
differences but-
>>Roy Freed: Yeah, parallel processing.
Yeah.
>>Male #1: Well, neural networks for example,
trying to make the computers be able to do
the sorts of things that humans-
>>Roy Freed: Yeah
>>Male #1: -can do
>>Roy Freed: Oh sure.
>>Male #1: -ends up being a great challenge.
Obviously there are gaps there, but one thing
that you seem to have not touched on and I
wonder whether you-
>>Roy Freed: Thank you
>>Male #1: -is the changing of the human mind
as a result of working with computers.
All I hear on this topic is people's cynicism;
nobody's going to be able to find his way
around on the map anymore because they're
using mapping computers.
They can't use a dictionary because the computer
does that work for them.
But not going to the extent of actually coupling
the mind with the computer.
Have you thought about how peoples thinking
is changing as a result of the extension of
your thought to here's the data I was looking
for in Google search for example?
>>Roy Freed: I think that computers are mostly
significant for giving us this opening to
the mind and as aides, supplementary aides,
they're great but I think this opening up
is wonderful contribution they make.
And what I find amazing is how little people
who use computers really know how they work
and it's so simple and I think that in my
missionary effort that it could be a way to
encourage people to learn more about computers.
By the way, in thinking about this, I really
recently, I love writing essays on these aspects
of my general thinking.
And recently somehow my subconscious triggered
me to think about artificial intelligence.
Ray Kurzweil, this great futurist guru here
has the solution, there are going to be computers
that are superior to the mind.
Which I think is the silliest concept in the
world.
I think that, that artificial intelligence,
I think, is really only programming computers
to do specific activities like play chess
and things like that.
But when you think about the human mind, it
is not, while it is a controlling mechanism
for the related human body as an encompassing
machine or system, the two are so interrelated
they're inseparable.
And to think of artificial intelligence as
a separate mind it's unreasonable.
The mind needs a supporting body and I can't
quite picture an independent mind as a robot,
pure robot tagging along with a cart that's
the body that forages for nutrition and operates
as a chemical factory to support the mind
and a power generator for creating the pulse
signals.
I mean I think that it's so important to analyze
the realities and not be taken up by these
flashy ideas.
I think Ray is brilliant but I think, I dunno
if you'd agree with me but I think he's off
the wall because it just isn't realistic in
the approach he's taking.
Yeah?
>>Male #2: [unintelligible] part of what he
is proposing is that people will be able to
move their minds into computers in some way.
And the various ways people think about how
to get your mind out of your brain into a
machine is interesting just to think about.
Whether it's possible in any way.
[chuckles] Does it involve, you know, projecting
a hundred or a thousand years or however,
will the computers ever be advanced enough
to conceive of that as a probability?
>>Roy Freed: I think the computers can only
supplements that the human mind is so fundamental
and so amazing that I think that we're limited
to using them to supplement the mind which
can be great.
And I do that in sort of a primitive way and
I also do that by inspiring me to think more
deeply about the mind.
I think that is the approach, I don't know
if I'm right or not but that seems to me to
be what it's all about.
Yeah?
>>Male #3: using your model of studying the
computer to learn about the mind to some extent
answered the question.
We have virtual machines, that is a computer
can run within it a number of things, each
of which feels like it is an independent computer.
>>Roy Freed: Yeah.
>>Male #3: It's relatively easy [unintelligible]
the easiest of course is the internal one
thinks it's identical to the outer one-
>>Roy Freed: Yeah.
>>Male #3: -the more difference you get, the
more you have to advance the technology of
making the computers basically.
With the software and the operating systems
in order to be able to simulate a different
kind of processor chip or altogether a different
way of operating.
For example, a virtual machine which thinks
like the human mind presumably can't be built
until you can have the basic computer be able
to think like the human mind to some extent.
So we will have to get computers presumably,
who can be.
Ooo, I just used [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Roy Freed: Yeah, sure.
>>Male #3: -perspective, get the concept of
self.
And then it's a lot of work above that to
basically model the entire human body and
mind as one, as you said.
The mind and the muscles are very linked,
they're very linked, they're not separate
devices.
They're attached to each other and so you
could imagine the number of years it might
take to make a computer than can think like
a person.
If that's possible.
Double to get to a point where you could actually
put a human's mind into it.
>>Roy Freed: I think, and again I feel so
modest about this because I'm not a neuroscientist
but I think that the operation of the human
mind devised by evolution by natural section
is so unique, is so elusive in the very details
of coding facts and ideas in the electrochemical
pulse signals in the mind.
I find it difficult to imagine that people
would ever be able to emulate that in computers.
But that's my present thinking.
But recently I noted in the newspaper and
I find it invaluable reading a newspaper,
especially the New York Times.
A computer system was devised to replicate
some medical aspect enables doing research
on the computer instead of directly on, what
would be on animal models, counterparts of
your mind.
But I, that's a very fascinating development
but I just find it hard to really expect that
neuroscientists can picture those individual
pulse signals and how they work.
And I also think it's fascinating when you
have the computer model to realize how the
circuitry of the mind is segmented and how
like in computers the segments are joined,
are assigned significance.
And I find it fascinating and I'm thinking
and how the segments in computers are connected
by switches and the programs activate the
switches to conduct thinking, the counterpart
of thinking.
The carrying out the processes.
And it caused me to wonder well how this is
in the mind and then I thought about synapses.
And synapses being the opposite of switches
in that they're always open and you have to
find a way to jump them.
And I was able, uniquely, to meet a professor
at MIT in the McGovern Institute for Brain
Research who's supposed to be an expert on
synapses.
And he immediately helped by saying "well
synapses operate by modulation" and as an
engineer, as sort of an amateur engineer,
I realized what happens in programs is they
generate added impulse to cause as appropriate
the electrochemical pulse signals that represent
facts and ideas into particular segments of
the mind in order to conduct the type of thinking
that's desired.
So I'm just sort of trying to give you relatively
an example or how I think having an engineering
aptitude and a systems approach and getting
this sort of superficial understanding that
I have so enables people to understand better
who they are, how they work and I would hope
idealistically that if they gain this knowledge
that they can realize how they're being imposed
upon on by the inadequacy of the mind through
ideology and the like and can be encouraged
to overcome that by objective critical thinking
using their creativity.
I mean, I find this exciting [chuckles] and
I just wonder does it resonate with your people
who are so much more aware of technology of
computers and the potential?
Go ahead please.
>>Male #4: I observe the longer people are
adamant on sticking with their limitations
even when there's limitations [unintelligible]-
>>Roy Freed: Oh yeah, oh.
>>Male #4: -that is the product of outside
forces.
>>Roy Freed: Yeah.
>>Male #4: Their sense of self is tied up
with it and I think in this country, more
than most others, we need to develop a culture
that values thought more.
For people to do the thinking that would get
them to decide they don’t have to just be
stuck with the thing [unintelligible]-
>>Roy: It's so idealist but so needed but
I don’t think we're really worse than anybody
I mean people are so infected with ideology,
religious prejudices, bigotry and it's human
and it's so easy when you have ideology you
don’t have to think, you've got the answers.
It's such a, it's a curse and I'm a missionary
I have to admit [laughs] and I just have this
feeling that thinking along the lines that
I have developed, I think, so beautifully,
I mean I'm thrilled.
I think that it's an ideal contribution for
people to behave individually and society.
And I just wonder if some of these ideas are
ideal means for education, for teaching people
to empower them and not be victims of the
traditional ideologies and mindset and the
like.
And I think it really enhances individuality
and the persona and the like.
It's like painting a picture, and it's, I'm
having the most exciting experience I can
imagine.
And you know how old I am?
I'm 95.
[laughs] And I think it's so fascinating and
how this happened, I have no idea for people
who ask me for my secret.
Who the hell has the secret?
But I'm just thrilled that it happened this
way and in writing my auto-biography, I look
for clues.
For example, I go through my parents who are
very ordinary.
My mother came from Vilna, Lithuania, at 16
before the First World War.
I have no idea what education she had, I was
too interested in myself to find out.
I'm so sorry about that; she was very open
minded, never was religious in a formal way.
Which I am certainly not.
My father was a first generation here, his
father came from Belarus because of the Kishinev
Pogrom there that caused the Jews to start
leaving.
And he was a very open minded man.
I think my mother was more intelligent than
he was but he was affable, friendly and very
decent and he gave me a very open growing
up which I treasure.
So in the course of thinking and writing my
autobiography, these facets kind of turn up
and I think that this isn't, to me, it's an
ideal frame of reference to be a decent human
being and work toward a better society .
You have any more questions?
You're good.
[laughter]
>>Male #5: This question, sir, combines your
two areas of the law and the computers and
the mind.
Which is, you mentioned intellectual property,
I believe that the, at some point, the computer
technology our ability to build intelligent
software, will advance to the point where
we can write a general program which can create
things, at least the main ingredient, it's
harder to [unintelligible] but be a creative
force for coming up with stuff we recognize
as being new and innovative things that we
previously had assumed only humans could do.
So the question is; when do we acknowledge
that the software is really the owner, the
creator of this new stuff as opposed to us
who may own the software?
And it's gonna be a long while after that
where the computer may assert its own supplements,
that this is the creator, we have to at least
acknowledge it
>>Roy Freed: I think we're trying, I don’t
know if I got exactly what you're driving
at but I think that understanding the human
mind as its programed by itself creation and
by learning from the environment, is an ideal
basis for working into the computer technology
to realize, it's so hard to really understand
but I think it's valuable to think in that
context.
Yes?
>>Male #6: I was just going to say maybe your
question is more like at what point can we
say that a computer has creativity?
That this was a creative product of the computer
itself as opposed to its non-autonomous behavior
because we pushed it's button and so it created
an output.
>>Roy Freed: I wonder about the ability ever
to make computers truly creative like the
human mind.
The ability of the subconscious to combine
disparate things, it’s a most amazing phenomenon
to create something new from two different
things.
I mean, I wonder if people will ever be smart
enough but I don’t know.
Yes?
>>Male #7: when you see criterion to define
[unintelligible], is when a computer can either
make itself better or make others that are
better than it.
And that involves or continues to be continuing
in a new direction of improvement, then it
has taken on something of a mind of its own
that is no longer our creation.
It's hard to apply that throughout our past,
there have been airfoils created by computers
decades ago which nobody imagined would fly
but I think they you know, segmented surface.
By segment they tired mutations and oh this
way gets more lift and they morphed in the
computer and many iterations to a shape that
turned out flew.
>>Roy Freed: But they had to be told how to
do that.
>>Male #7: Well, right.
>>Roy Freed: yeah.
>>Male #7: Even if it went to ways that they
didn't explicitly didn’t need to be told,
it's hard to make a criteria but when it comes
to making the computer better than humans
have made a computer before.
That's when where, where you can, it isn't
that we didn’t go in that direction, clearly
making the computer able to do computer improvement
was a direction that we were striving for
and the computer outdid us.
If we can keep that up for a year of improvement
then clearly it has crossed the line.
>>Roy Freed: But that's realistic isn't it?
>>Male #7: it has not a human mind equivalent
but it is crossing a line-
>>Roy Freed: yeah.
>>Male #7: -that clearly has made it create
things that we were unable.
>>Roy Freed: I think when we will [unintelligible],
I'm sort of conservative about my ideas, I
think they're great [chuckles] but I'm never
fairly certain but I think that the more we
know about the mind, the more we understand
the possibilities and limitations of computers
and I think that's the beauty of having this
technology.
>>Male #8: There's been some interesting work
in computational simulation of neurons-
>>Roy Freed: Yeah
>>Male #8: I saw an article in Scientific
American or something, and I just wonder like,
suppose we have- how many neurons do we have?
10 to the 15th or something in our brains
that-
>>Roy Freed: An awful lot.
>>Male #8: An awful lot and so it takes such
and such an amount of computer power now to
stimulate one neuron, is it, I mean is it
just a question of scale?
Like, suppose we did build a computer big
enough to stimulate 10 to the 15th neurons,
would, do you think there might be a possibility
for that ensemble to do the things that this
[unintelligible] does?
>>Roy Freed: I have to be humble and say that's
something for you to answer more than I but
I really have no idea.
But it's amazing what evolution and natural
selection did, I mean it's just unbelievable
in how it happened as responses to handicaps
in living.
How people overcame, over long periods of
time, those handicaps and improved the physical
structure of the mind.
By the way, this matter of knowledge, what
I find so interesting is the fact that acquiring
knowledge is an acquired characteristic which
is not passed on through reproduction.
And that’s why for each person, they have
to create their own unique body of knowledge
and it's passed on only through external means
books and recordings and things like that
and recordings in minds.
And also in connection with my ideas about
art, what I find fascinating the analogy of
a human mind as a sculpture.
I think it's fascinating that it's constantly,
it's plastic, and constantly shaped by the
acquisition and creation of knowledge and
that represents paste-ons to this physical
structure within the skull that, in turn,
determine emotions and action.
And I think that it's just a fascinating thing
to think that how we are sculptures and sculptors
at the same time and I love to draw this analogy
to realize, in various fields, I mean in terms
of art and the like.
Yes?
>>Male #9: So you're saying that you appreciate
how biology, through biology we evolved the
intelligence of how the mind is a product
of that evolution.
The question of how machines might do it I
believe it probably has to involve a similar
kind of evolution, because partly we don’t
understand what it is that makes up how we
operate.
Even if we did understand it'd very actually
difficult to build and explicitly do it like
we do it.
I think so modeling of the brain is probably
not the right way to do it directly.
It's more about its functionality and I think
that there might be a lot of [unintelligible]
evolutionary kind of principles going on in
the brain itself as thinking process is kinda
like natural selection of ideas is whatever
the predominant ideas are that you kinda reinforce
by yourself awareness's-
>>Roy Freed: Yeah.
>>Male #9: that's how it works.
So as to whether you can actually build machines
that would actually be as intelligent as us
be possibly, if we acknowledge it, self-aware
as we are, I think it has to happen by way
of evolution.
>>Roy Freed: Yeah.
What I find fascinating is that the two men
who invented the ENIAC computer had, could
not have had any idea of how the mind works.
It was well before neuroscientists had realized
the existence of circuitry and the pulse signals
in the mind.
So they drew on knowledge of physics and systems
engineering, things like that.
And yet the mind is triggered.
I also, in looking at the history of interest
in computing, it goes way back through so
many mechanical efforts.
It seemed to me that the creation of electronic
digital computer was inevitable, we were working
toward that path over many years and so much
of the need was for the commercialization
of electricity made possible by Thomas Alva
Edison, which was just such a boost to that.
It's fascinating to take this whole goddamn
picture and put it together, it's just fascinating
and exciting just in itself.
Thank you so much for this ability and opportunity
to expatiate and if I've stimulated curiosity,
desire to talk again I would love it, I just,
to me this is my value in living.
Thank you.